-Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You're here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I want to wish everyone
a very happy Thanksgiving.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Happy Thanksgiving!
Happy Thanksgiving.
I didn't miss celebrating
over Zoom,
but I definitely missed
that mute button.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, the holiday
is pretty much over,
which means right now everyone's
back with their immediate family
talking smack about
everyone else.
[ Laughter ]
On Thanksgiving, there are
always two kinds of families --
the one that wakes up early
to run a 5K
and the one that stays up late
to reheat all the food
they just put away. It's like,
"Alright, who's hungry?
Let's make some sandwiches.
Come on!"
I read that more than half
of all people
said that they were
exercising in the weeks
leading up to Thanksgiving.
You know, it might be time
to cut back
when we're all training
for a meal, don't you feel?
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, the first Thanksgiving
was celebrated
400 years ago in 1621.
That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was the first time
someone finished eating,
then looked at their spouse
like,
"When are they gonna leave?"
[ Laughter ]
But I hope everyone had
a nice Thanksgiving.
It was a fun day of trying
to figure out...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I hope you had fun.
Yeah, it was a fun day of
trying to figure out
if Uncle Ralph's vaccinated
without actually asking
if he's vaccinated.
[ Laughter ]
How are you doing, Uncle Ralph?
Is that a Band-Aid
on your shoulder?
[ Laughter ]
Second shot hurt worse
than the first one?
[ Laughter ]
Third one?
That's right, people took
vaccination status
very seriously,
though I thought it was weird
to see a bouncer
outside Grandma's House.
I.D. and vax card.
[ Laughter ]
You can go see Nona.
Of course, a lot of people like
to drink wine on Thanksgiving.
I love how --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love how my aunt puts away
three glasses and said,
"Boy, that turkey
really makes you sleepy."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, 63% of people drink wine,
19% drink beer,
and 10% drink liquor,
while the other 8%
mix all that together
and wake up on Christmas.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They're here
in the audience tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome.
And in the band. Wow.
This year, as always,
the food people feared to cook
the most was the turkey.
If you take it out too late,
it's dry.
If you take it out too early,
you got to rub it down
with Purell.
[ Laughter ]
Turkeys are always
scary to cook,
especially if you deep-fry it.
The only thing more dangerous
than your dad saying,
"I'm going to go deep-fry
the turkey" is him saying,
"I'm going to go knock
the icicles off the gutters."
[ Laughter ]
Whoa! Oh, my God!
Actually, I read
the tofu turkeys went up
in sales this year.
It's a little different.
Instead of people saying
white or dark meat,
they go, "Gray
or slightly grayer meat?"
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, I read that
most Americans prefer
Thanksgiving leftovers
to the actual dinner.
[ Cheers and applause ]
When asked why, they say,
"'Cause I get to eat it alone
over the sink."
[ Laughter ]
That's the best. Come on.
I read that air travel this week
was expected to nearly reach
pre-pandemic levels
to accommodate
all of the extra passengers.
Delta and American
added flights,
while Spirit added another row
of folding chairs to the wings.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, a lot of people
were traveling
for the first time
in over a year.
So things were
a little hectic.
Here, check out this news story
I saw about it.
-Many are traveling
for the first time since 2019.
So expect to deal with all sorts
of people at the airport,
including the person
in the TSA line
who has apparently never taken
their shoes off in their life,
the people in Zone 17
who stand in the way
while everyone else
is boarding,
the person chugging a gallon
of Aquafina
because they didn't realize
it counted as a liquid,
people who don't have
their boarding pass handy,
even though they just spent
half an hour in line
being told to have it handy,
and, of course, the hardest
thing to deal with -- babies.
-That's right.
Yeah, interesting.